okay so you know me i like doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
you suck though it's definitely divided
the fan base i fall on the side that
thinks it was a roller coaster ride that
contained some of the best horror scenes
in the mcu wonder was a great villain to
me and watching this chase across
several universes felt like one of the
funnest rides i'd had in the marvel
universe for a long time however things
were originally going to be different to
what we got and if you cast your mind
back to the face for announcement then
you'll remember scott derrickson was
initially behind the project he just
come off the back of the original doctor
strange film and at the event he said
they were gearing up to create the first
horror movie in the mcu however derekson
in the studio ended up parting ways over
what was said to be creative differences
though rumors flew around the project at
the time that said marvel were afraid of
how far he was going to go with it this
has sort of been debunked during an
interview with empire kevin feige said
that the studios still love scott and
though no one really believes them it
was genuinely just down to creative
differences to me though i'll always
think that feige really said what scott
derrickson and then he was gone since
then scott has gone on to direct the
phenomenal black phone and it might make
you wonder what his original plan was
gonna be well we've bloody got it after
sorting through leaks interviews and
what insiders close to the movie have
said we've pieced together elements of
what the original plan for the film was
supposed to be to join us as we take a
trip through an alternate timeline in
order to ask what if now if you love the
video 3000 then please hit the thumbs up
button and make sure you subscribe
because i love you in every universe
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
now first up there was very much three
versions of this film with the first one
being derrickson's and then the plan
with raymies both pre and mid pandemic
you might remember that multiverse of
madness was slightly to release before
no way home but sony refused to budge on
their december release date which led to
them swapping places america chavez was
originally going to be introduced in
this film and then come nowhere home
she'd be the person that pulled across
andrew and toby this was shown in a lot
of concept after the film and it makes
way more sense than having ned discover
he's a wizard however sony aka the
studio behind the greatest movie of all
time mobius said nope and thus even
raymie's version had to have elements of
every shot in order to narratively build
off the back of it now the original
version of the film was meant to center
heavily around america chavez being
trained by strange and wong on top of
this we would also have them helping
wander to harness their abilities after
the events of one division unlike what
we got in the final release wonder was
trying to redeem herself after west view
and she'd start off the movie by being a
fallen idol who was seeking out
redemption now eventually she did turn
into a villain much like the final film
but this was over time and only after
she learned about the multiverse through
seeing what america could do she was
also more of a puppet for the film's
true villain who we'll talk about more
in just a bit they wanted to spread
madness throughout the multiverse and
this would be accomplished by her being
a nexus being this is someone who's the
same in every reality and thus the bad
guys could create branches through every
reality by using her however she would
turn bad at the end and face off against
the heroes due to wanting her kids back
michael waldron aka the film's writer
even talked about how this evolved over
time in things like the raimi version 2.
he said that originally they wanted
wanna to turn at the end of the film but
at the time they realized it was just
dead air and decided to put things in
place from the earth so they could do a
liz truss and hit the ground bit of a uk
political joke there for my american
chumps chums with a p in it see a chump
we knew
that we wanted wanda to be in it i think
originally it was a version where wanda
was maybe gonna turn bad at the end that
was a big change that i made and i had a
strong perspective on making her a
villain from the get-go it was always
like well that'll happen in an avengers
movie or something
my perspective was why are we letting
some other movie get
the best villain ever now in terms of
america being introduced we would also
get clear appearing much earlier in the
movie she would be a love interest from
the art rather than strange going back
and forth with multiple versions of
christine in the comics the pair got
married at one point and this movie had
elements that would show the foundations
of their relationship being put in place
and they were also going to be joined by
brother voodoo who would act as an ally
i'm not sure whether this was changed to
rin trot for the final draft but either
way voodoo was in early plans for the
movie now as for the villains this was
going to be both shuma gorath and also
nightmare building off the back of what
if gorath was going to be a multiversal
entity that wanted to use his enforcer
nightmare to manipulate wander into
wrecking havoc across the multiverse
through using her as a vessel he wanted
to spread madness throughout the entire
multiverse and then this would enable
him to consume all of reality ashuma
sent out nightmare who then captured
america and he took her hostage the
wizards then start to learn about chuma
gorath and they discover that he'd been
defeated in the past by the wizard
cagliostro he also appeared in episode 4
of what if and once more we were gonna
watch strange encounter him and find a
way to take out the villain this
involved a mystical ritual that had a
heavy basis in the occult and it would
have added to the horror side of the
movie in the final version we of course
got strange stream walking into his
corpse which stirred the spirits of the
damned and i imagine that this might
have been along the same lines now on
the other side of this we also had mordo
from the 616 who returned after the
post-credits scene in the first strange
movie he was still hunting wizards and
after he also learned of gorat's plans
he attempted to kill america before
nightmare could take her to him kill
america who is he insert politician name
that you don't like but i won't say as i
don't want to offend anyone and make
this into a political channel hey having
that
too many political jokes in this video
paul unsubscribe a huge shout out to um
stranger on twitter for putting together
what was going to happen in the final
battle for the film this would
reportedly take place in schumer gorat's
realm which was known as the realm of
dead universes this contained all of the
realities that the villain had consumed
and here nightmare would unleash his
full powers this had the villain
bringing forth physical manifestations
of the character's worst fears and it's
also at this point that wonder would
fully change she would realize that
there was a way to get her kids back
she'd turn against the heroes and though
she'd help them to defeat nightmare and
gorath it set a lot of things in place
for the future rather than quote-unquote
killing her off like how they did in the
final release she was used more as sonny
t's future showdowns and this would
possibly even tie into a house of m
style movie although there's been stuff
that's clearly based on it you've never
had her truly change the entirety of
reality like how she did in that book
and it would definitely be an
interesting direction to take things a
lot of the complaints i see about
multiverse of madness are that a change
was too sudden but having this movie do
it and then setting up things for the
future would probably be the smarter way
to go about it now this would massively
change up the way that the movie was
eventually given to us and honestly i
probably prefer the focus from the off
being on wonder being the villain
however this seems like it handles the
pieces better such as moro coming back
around and there was actually a scene in
the original reimy version that too had
him dying after being killed by wonder
as of now though he's still out in the
mcu and it's going to be interesting to
see if they end up bringing across
villains like nightmare in the future we
of course got something similar to
gorath in the form of galgantos who
appeared in the raimi version as one of
wander's minions having the creature as
the main villain would have completely
flipped things on its head though and i
think it would have tied more into what
if now whether this would have been
better or not is difficult to tell as
these ideas don't really paint out the
full picture you also don't get elements
like the illuminati or the cameos that
we had throughout the film either way
that's everything i could find on the
film and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this information and also
whether you would have preferred this to
what we got or not drop them all in the
comments below and as a thank you you'll
be entered into a competition where
we're giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the outline
we pick the comments at random and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
emails to watch then make sure you check
out our full marvel slide breakdown
which contains all the confirmed and
rumored upcoming mcu projects that'll be
linked on screen right now and hopefully
i see you over there right after this if
not then thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul you take care
yourself peace